nicolas vidal est ce que la république
en marche fait la politique du
gouvernement selon vous ben oui il
aurait plus qu'un marché fictivement
comme l'a dit alexis n est pas du tout
ancré dans les territoires il faut quand
même mettre en évidence ses résultats ce
soir nadège c'est quand même une
abstention massive on l'a dit mais je le
dis je les ai déjà dit plusieurs fois
sur l'antenne
c'est une insurrection populaire
silencieuse ce qui se passe au jeu dans
ce pays et il faut quand même bien
prendre en compte de ça alors j'ai
regardé avant de passer en direct les
discours politiques des uns et des
autres on en reviendra probablement mais
on m'en donne on n'en parle pas cette
attention très peu c'est une espèce de
verbiage absolument même incroyable
effrayant notamment xavier bertrand qui
s'est posée qui s'est posé presque en
présidentiable rendre bloqué à quelques
minutes mais à un moment donné ces
résultats doivent être regardées à
l'homme de cette abstention massive qui
pour moi je vous le dit tout de go c'est
un acte politique
c'est un acte politique on a évincé vous
savez l'idée de pêcheurs à la ligne
il ya une dizaine d'années ce qui les
20% qu'il n'avait jamais voté mais ce
soir vraiment ce qu'on doit voir c'est
cet acte politique d'extension un an des
présidentielles et bien entendu pour
revenir là dessus emmanuel macron c'est
une défaite cinglante bien entendu on va
avoir les éléments de langage qui vont
arriver déjà depuis avec aurore bergé il
ya quelques minutes sur un plateau
compte deux confrères mais et on parlera
sûrement quand vous envoyez cinq
ministres dans les hauts de france et
que vous prenez une claque comme ça je
crois qu'au moment de donner demain
matin même ce soir autour de stanislas
guérini de jean castex
il va falloir qu'ils les petites
discussions mais je ne les crois pas à
ces petites discussions voyez vous chers
nadège une